chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that are run into might surprise
you you're gonna get a glimpse into the
light of a self-made millionaire these
folks are hard at work you don't want to
miss it people this is everyday
millionaires
we're here sitting at our hopefully our
forever home enjoying the lake behind us
when we got married with over six and a
half years ago we had close to 800,000
dollars in debt and it's been quite -
quite the story quite the ride to get
here quite the ride
I'm John this is cricket were the Alan's
I actually was the one that reason why
we've had so much debt I got into no
money down real estate and had mortgaged
my former house with my husband that I
was married to then and we bought
fifteen rentals so I ended up eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt and I did not know how it was
possibly gonna end up paying it off and
I had a life insurance policy and there
was a there was a brief thought of
committing suicide because at least some
of the debt would be paid off because I
just didn't see how it could be possible
that we could get out of the hole that I
had created I was at work one day and
just had a very little hope I was very
hopeless I was at my bottom financially
one of my friends heard me and he pulled
me aside and he said you know I'm I'm
teaching this thing at church actually I
don't even think he would have said
Church because it would have made me run
because I was not going to church at
that point he said it's Financial Peace
University and he might want to check it
out and I was desperate
and so I I I listened
so cuz he had some hope I grabbed hold
of it like a life preserver
but part of grabbing hold of it was
having to accept the fact that he was
talking pretty frankly about Jesus and
about Christianity and I met God when I
was probably 12 years old and I turned
my life over to Jesus but I definitely
wasn't walking a Christian lifestyle at
all if I hadn't been so desperate for
help with the financial part I probably
would have walked away and would have
been unbeliever the rest of my life God
uses things for for our good and I
honestly think he allowed me to fall on
my face
financially because it caused me to come
back to him I got an extra job I was
working I took one day off a month and I
just worked like banshee and John and I
started dating and by the time we got
married I had paid off everything except
for the rentals then here comes John and
we get married enough I bring another
two hundred fifty thousand into the
marriage so we we jump back up to almost
eight hundred thousand again and that
yeah every penny that was left over went
went to that it would be four hundred
and twenty-five dollars and 32 cents
would go to debt and we live very
frugally we didn't have cable for five
years and we have cars that are both 10
years old went on camping trips we tried
to figure out ways that we could enjoy
ourselves frugally so we worked really
hard and it was so refreshing to have
someone who is on the same page
because we paid 1 million 14 thousand
dollars in debt in exactly 7 years it's
it's just like a marathon we just kept
on going and going and one day we looked
up and we were there
[Music]
he had talked about wanting to live on
the lake the whole time we've known each
other mission this is a big part of my
family history having a place that we
could give them a place to common you
know take a week two weeks to be able
just just to have a place that they
could come back and really enjoy like
that so it's a pretty big be able to
take that so so here I hear this dream
and I'm like there is no way that we're
gonna be able to afford a house that
would accommodate basically two families
but we did it we we got out of that here
we are here we are she started out with
basically a financial Journal this is
this is the second book I filled and and
I got a pretty once I knew that I was
gonna be doing it every every month for
a long time and I would write down what
we owed each each one of them line item
eat what we owed and here's what the
balances of our checking account the
balances of our savings account our
emergency fund it was like a celebration
every single month and you're seeing
this debt slowly going down and then you
could see the net worth slowly going up
I keep on going back to the word hope it
just really energized me every month to
be able to see okay we're doing it it's
it's happening you know it's that baby
steps you're getting applauding up a
mountain that you're we're getting to
see that we're getting somewhere that we
can look back and we can see that where
we actually are getting somewhere we got
down to that last final month and we had
one cheque to write this was to pay off
our personal residence
so it was to be debt free including her
house and we wrote that last check and
we had the Christmas tree up in the
background we did a little video and we
took a big old chain I had and and then
we put it around us we did a a personal
debt-free screen the chains are gone and
that was a pretty thrilling moment to be
able to do that we were investing in our
401ks having a little bit of money going
in there just overtime constantly over
time and allowing that money to work and
we didn't have to work to make that
money work we work terribly hard when
there was renovations to be done on a
house we got in there we'd work 9:00 to
5:00 and in five to nine it was we did
we just we just continued to plow into
using our abilities and our skills to
reduce any kind of expenses to make
those improvements we sold some of the
rental properties we have nine rentals
it's not just the stocks that we have in
the 401k and it's not just our income
and it's not just that we work hard but
we also have these paid off houses that
somebody else is enjoying the living
those houses and giving us you know five
to eight hundred dollars a month in
exchange for us to let them stay there
and it's not just any one thing that
really has helped us get here
one of my goals was to be able to meet
Dave and to thank him because we didn't
just half a million dollars I I came
back to Christ you know and
[Music]
you know I do have peace and it's not
just the financial piece so it's just
been it truly has been life-changing
it's not just financially it truly is
life changing having this this vision of
where you want to go and I would bring
up ever since we were together about
having this house on the lake and
keeping that in front of me was a big
part of why I stayed and was able to
stay committed to to paying off every
month even down to the penny of what was
left over here we are sitting on the
lake and in a house that we can use to
bless weathers with we're over a million
dollars in net worth and we laugh and
talk about the fact that you know if
it's possible and we want to get there
then let's go for two you know our cup
truly is running ever and it's allowing
us to to not only have enough for
ourselves for our family we can truly
blessed so many other people because we
have enough and and had we not gotten
out of debt
it would have been harder to be able to
give but we truly can give with an open
hand to now because we know we're going
to be okay
eight years ago I personally owed almost
750 thousand dollars in debt and I was
totally hopeless and through this
program eight years later Don and I now
have a net worth of 1.7 million dollars
and hope is real
it really is
[Music]
[Music]